you get arrested and free sorry i'm bad
reading you get arrested and for one
call you can only call another barstool
employee who is it can't be each other
oh who's going to pick up but also it's
like who's got kind of like bailing
around
or like who can who can rely on that
they might pick up but they might be
like [ __ ] face or they might be whatever
who's not going to give you a hard time
about it who's reliable
we're just checking all boxes of things
barcelona
yeah i'm like going down the line who's
sober and reliable
[Laughter]
i can't call you what the [ __ ] you
actually probably wouldn't answer will
you be in jail with me
i would always answer big cat
what do you see in town that week
i've actually never talked to big cats
i don't i jenna's done with big cats
number one
who the [ __ ] would i call realistically
and i and i have to call a barstool
employee that everybody knows i'm gonna
probably go kelly she's like an older
sister kelly keegs she would she's home
oh i'm calling kate okay i'm calling
kate you gonna make her do that
she would in a heartbeat and she'd bring
cash she'd bring cash yeah cash to bail
you out or casual kid both